fue una figura muy controversial en
Venezuela se le atribuye haberle dado el
soporte institucional a los gobiernos
Diego Chávez y Nicolás Maduro para su
permanencia en el poder a través del
voto esto mediante cuestionados comicios
presidenciales estuvo al frente del
Consejo Nacional electoral en la
presidencia durante 14 años desde el año
2006 hasta el año 2020 y bajo su gestión
fueron denunciadas múltiples
irregularidades como en el registro
electoral permanente la migración de
votantes la modificación de circuitos
electorales todo esto estrategias que
según sus detractores favorecían al
partido de gobierno en el 2018 estaba al
frente de los cuestionados comicios
presidenciales en los que resultó electo
Nicolás maduro y que fueron desconocidos
por gran parte de la comunidad
internacional a su salida del cne fue
nombrada rectora de la universidad
experimental de las artes y en el año
2021 pasó a formar parte del gabinete de
Nicolás maduro como ministra de
Educación Universitaria un cargo por el
que también fue cuestionada divisa y
lucena fue sancionada por Estados Unidos
la Unión Europea y Canadá tras ser
señalada de que mediante acciones
emprendidas Bajo su cargo en el Consejo
Nacional electoral haber socavado la
democracia en Venezuela y el estado de
derecho su muerte fue anunciada por la
vicepresidenta delsi Rodríguez a través
de las redes sociales no ofreció mayores
detalles sobre las causas sin embargo se
conocía que desde el año 2011 batallaba
contra el